bonjour à tous ça va waouh inquiétez pas
ça va être rapide
le 27 octobre 2005
deux jeunes adolescents zyed et bouna
meurent électrocutés dans un poste d f
en tentant d'échapper à un contrôle de
police dans la foulée des jeunes de
clichy sous bois vont se soulever contre
les forces de l'ordre qui vont rétorquer
quelques jours plus tard en envoyant une
bombe lacrymogène
au pied d'une mosquée en plein mois de
ramadan s'ensuivent des émeutes dans les
quartiers
d'abord dans le 9 3 puis dans tous les
quartiers de france
j'avais à l'époque 19 ans et j'ai grandi
en seine saint denis ainsi que toute ma
famille une bonne partie de mon enfance
et mon adolescence je me suis sentie
très concernée par l'évènement qui se
passait parce que comme une bonne partie
de ces jeunes qui eux s'exprimer par la
violence
j'étais moi même issu de l'immigration
et je pouvais ressentir le malaise
qu'ils avaient vis-à-vis du système ou
de la france mais ce qui m'a vraiment
frappé à ce moment là c'est le rapport
et le traitement des médias à double
tranchant d'un côté le gamin que j'étais
me disait tout le monde en parle
les pouvoirs publics vont pas pouvoir
ignorer la difficulté qu'il ya en france
l'harmonie la politique on a à unifier
des français qui sont divers et
notamment dans certains quartiers
l'épreuve ces problématiques qui se sont
accumulées depuis des dizaines d'années
et que l'état manifestement n'arrive pas
et n'arrive toujours pas endiguée de
l'autre en fait c'était cette peur en
voyant semaine après semaine se poser
une caricature de cette fracture sociale
qui s'imposait comme une chape de plomb
sur la société
ce dialogue de société qui était dû
notamment au langage approximatif
d'abord employé par les médias puis qui
se répandait au niveau des gens dans
leurs dialogues au quotidien on
entendait parler de guerre civile
le terme à proprement employés était
celui là qui étaient répandues on en
entendait parler que la france était à
feu et à sang
pourtant les quartiers concernés si on
les additionne ne font ne représentera
qu à peine 0 01 % du territoire
on a même parlé un moment de révolte
musulmane bref les approximations de
langage en fait qui composaient qui
polluaient et qui perturbent le dialogue
deux sociétés se retrouver au niveau des
gens et a fortiori dans une société
diverse créer une complexité j'ai vu au
fil des semaines se poser une rhétorique
implicite du e contre nous avec deux
camps d'un côté plutôt une population
qui serait blanche conservatrice au
moins voire raciste et qui aurait un
intérêt à entretenir des plafonds de
verre et le système discriminatoire
l'arrangerait donc le maintenir de
l'autre côté une population immigrée qui
serait soit fainéante et ou
génétiquement violente et qui bien
entendu soit porte là le voile la
capuche et mesdames et messieurs bien
sûr la fameuse casquette à l'envers
le dialogue de société perturbé comme il
l'était à ce moment là était non
seulement au fond sans offensant pour
les uns comme pour les autres
d'autant plus que nous devons faire face
à deux défis le premier c'est celui de
la diversité de nos sociétés sont
diverses et vont l'être de plus en plus
qu'on le veuille ou non
l'explosion des flux migratoires nous
mêmes étudiants en france on a la chance
de pouvoir partir facilement faire un
erasmus à l'étranger et pourquoi pas
s'expatrier il vivre de même que des
gens peuvent venir chez nous plus
facilement mais cet enjeu n'est pas
seulement l'enjeu qui se passe en france
c'est l'enjeu pour toutes les sociétés
du monde et c'est un mouvement avec
lequel il va falloir deal et le second
événement historique auquel nous
assistons mais je ne veux pas parler du
quatrième titre consécutif que le psg va
remporter cette année
zlatan si tu nous entends la paix à ton
âme plus tôt je veux parler bien entendu
de la crise d'internet qui est du larlé
remaniement qui sont dues l'essor et à
l'explosion du numérique de l'ère du
réseau où chaque domaine de la société
et frappé est remis en question par les
valeurs collaboratives participatif qui
bien sûr sont ouvre le champ des
possibles incroyable mais aussi ouvre
une ère de doutes et de remises en
question
il était beaucoup plus facile pour le
général de gaulle posé devant le rtf à
20h pendant que les français buvaient
leur soupe de nous raconter le récit
national et de nous raconter la grandeur
de la france et de créer une certaine
manière du lien social
aujourd'hui nous sommes potentiellement
7.5 milliards chaîne d'information
capable d'émettre de l'information et
d'en recevoir
on est passés ensemble d'un discours
d'une société à voix dominante à une
société à voix multiples où tout le
monde peut s'exprimer l'aigle et l'agora
2.0 pour ne pas dire l'agora 3.0 en
réalité est une agora où on n'est plus
réellement représenté par une petite
partie de personnes qui parlent au nom
tout le monde mais bien de 7,5 milliards
personnes potentiels qui peuvent dire
leurs avis leurs idées leur créativité
leur notion mais aussi leur violence
leur ras-le-bol et tout ça aujourd'hui
est un terreau est un phénomène nouveau
on est aussi dans cette génération face
à cet essor des personnes qui peuvent
qui peuvent s'exprimer dans une culture
du clash la parole est devenu assimilé
au conflit c'est l'ère des trailer des
trolls heures des oeuvres de la provoc
pour faire des vues pour faire des like
pour attirer des gens sur sa page mêmes
c'est devenu une stratégie politique
cette stratégie un peu offensive de de
poser des bases là des punchline c'est
devenu le code le la parole est devenu
un sport presque de combat et qui nous
obligent dans le temps court pour
attirer les gens par peur pour attirer
la peur c'est ce qui c'est le
sensationnel qui nous permettent de nous
faire entendre en réalité et c'est même
une stratégie lancé une stratégie
c'est comme ça que les émissions télé
sont faites ces honnart où on cultive
inconsciemment cette culture du
sensationnel et qui est en train dans
l'inconscient collectif de structurer la
parole à un sport de combat
en réalité dans tout le monde peut
prendre la parole mais on ne s'écoute
plus vraiment et dans ce brouhaha moi je
me suis posé la question à un moment
donné je me suis dit ok comment on fait
recréer dans la société des espaces où
la communication le dialogue pourrait se
faire de manière profonde et sincère et
constructive en 2012
je me suis rendu à l'université de
seine-saint-denis prix créé deux choses
un concours la prise de parole en public
et plus tard une année après une
formation à la prise de parole en public
ce concours donc ces programmes dits
éloquence ya fait consisté en deux temps
le premier un concours ouvert à tous les
jeunes de seine-saint-denis entre 18 et
30 ans qui peuvent venir
ils peuvent venir et défendre le propos
qui le souhaite que ce soit une idée
leur créativité
s'ils ont envie de tenir une parole de
colère contre la société tout le monde
peut s'exprimer que ce soit en rap en
slam en aller
impro son discours peu importe dès lors
que ce que tu viens nous dire et sincère
très rapidement des dizaines de jeunes
dès la première année ont participé au
concours on a eu des amphithéâtre plein
à craquer et pourtant l'été en plein
coeur du 9-3 et dans la société on avait
déjà une crispation sur la liberté
d'expression qui se mettait en place est
complètement en décalage avec ce qui se
passait chez nous en plein coeur de la
seine saint denis le deuxième programme
c'était une formation formation la prise
de parole en public pour travailler sur
la confiance en soi est justement
travaillé la parole avec un collectif en
groupe
une formation qui s'articule sur cinq
temps le premier c'est travailler sur la
prise de parole en milieu professionnel
les jeunes arrivent on leur demande quel
est ton rêve qu'est ce que tu veux faire
qu'est ce que tu as dans le vide et on
s'adapte sur 60 heures de semaine en
semaine à les accompagner à leur donner
les codes pour pouvoir aller au bout de
leur rêve
le second point structurer la pensée
structurée le discours là on va dire ça
un peu plus la partie aristotélicienne
le discours d'aristote l'exorde une
intro l'argumentation la réfutation la
péroraison structurer la pensée
troisième temps un rapport la prise de
la parole c'est pas uniquement quelque
chose de personnel c'est quelque chose
qu'on fait avec un groupe avec les
autres donc comprendre pourquoi est ce
que là mon coeur juste avant de rentrer
rentrée battait à 2000 à l'heure le
comprendre gestion gérer son stress le
positionnement de son corps appréhendé
en fait le rapport aux autres au delà du
simple fait de parler d'interagir avec
les autres
les autres points c'était de travailler
sur la créativité aller sur des prises
de paroles différentes par le slam la
poésie le théâtre aussi qui permette
l'introspection de se remettre en
question et essayer d'appréhender la
parole sur de nouveaux codes très
rapidement on a obtenu des résultats
d'un dès la première année donc des
dizaines de participants l'événement est
devenu un événement référence et en
seine-saint-denis où déjeunent pas
uniquement de l'université des jeunes
qui n'a d'ailleurs ne venait jamais à
l'université assister aux battles et en
ce qui concerne la formation y avait un
phénomène particulier qui se crée c'est
à dire que quand
parlait il venait il s'ouvrait aux
autres mais d'abord à eux-mêmes et du
coup dans ce cadre très intime en
s'ouvrant aux autres il y avait une
empathie un collectif qui était capable
d'aborder tous les sujets et de co
construire une réflexion et pas toujours
de changer d'avis mais en tout cas
d'évoluer de réfléchir et de s'enrichir
les uns des autres en 2015 pour la
deuxième année de la formation en voyant
qu'on était complètement à
contre-courant avec ce qui se passait
dans la société
j'ai décidé de réaliser un film qui
suivrait le plus fidèlement possible ce
qui se passait au niveau de la formation
et du concours en suivant ces jeunes à
la fois ordinaire parce que il ya
vingt-deux mille jeunes à l'université
de saint-denis y en a 25 mille autres
juste à côté à l'univers 7 villetaneuse
en tout cinquante mille jeunes qui sont
pas tous de banlieue mais pour beaucoup
d'entre eux qui le sont qu'ils ont des
intelligences des créativités des propos
des militantisme qui au demeurant dans
ces terres collectives sont
indispensables pour refaire société
mettre la lumière sur eux et suivent ni
plus ni moins ce qui se passait et qu'à
la fois il avait une dimension
extraordinaire parce que pendant 60
heures il venait le samedi de 9h30 à
19h30 pour se battre pour être
accompagnés pour qu'on les accompagne à
dire ce qu'ils avaient à apporter à la
société et qu'ils aillent au bout de
leurs rêves professionnels notamment le
premier jour de tournage c'était le 7
janvier 2015
la première fois qu'on les a filmés au
même moment la france entamait la pause
et de sakhri sur liberté d'expression
les attentes a éclaté de charlie hebdo
justement et les six semaines suivantes
pendant que toute la société se
tendaient que le dialogue de société et
est pour le coup vraiment très très très
très compliqué nous à nouveau une
famille se formait était capable
d'aborder tous les sujets y compris
celui de charlie hebdo dans une
dimension de respect et d'écouté
mutuelle et de co construction
je vous propose d'ailleurs le film
s'appelle à voix haute je vous propose
de regarder un court extrait j'étais
vraiment dit ce que je pensais quand
j'ai parlé des cordes harrachis gelé
vraiment pensé quand tu l'as dit en fait
je me suis dit je voyais là c'est donc
un coup de sable et cela je pense qu'on
peut pas rire de tout satanas
mensurations renversa le bloc bas c'est
peut-être pas un manque de respect mais
c'est délicat de rigoler de sa devant
lui tu vois comment tu fais pour savoir
que ça ne bloque sa troupe mais c'est ça
bave récession en fait il y arrive tout
le monde a lancé m donc en fait vous
droit qu'à une limite pour chaque
personne n'est pas possible on pourra
voir des cultes sensibilité différente
en france par thibaut moins dans la
culture de l'autodérision on peut rire
de tout en france à partir du moment où
certains cas une autre culture je pense
qu'il faut faire attention à partir du
moment où on dit ah non ça c'est du
domaine privé on peut pas toucher à mon
sens on peut pas toucher à non ça c'est
notre culture se comprend on veut pas
rigoler annonça si on commence comme ça
on arrête le mourre humour c'est un
combat et la parole c'est un combat
était qu une arme et moi je pense et
j'ai envie de faire des blagues qui vont
dans le bon sens et je sais qu'en fin de
mois ya des gens qui pensent pas comme
moi on va tous se dire dieudonné je
déteste et je détiens son humour et main
je suis très content qu'il puisse
s'exprimer et mais moi je vais utiliser
mon humour j'utilisais ma parole pour le
combattre
à choisir on a tous des sujets qu'on
n'aborde pas on a tous des sujets qu'on
aborde j'empêche personne de le faire
mais personnellement je sais que si je
vais blessé quelqu'un je ferai pas enfin
si je choix de blessés ou pas quelqu'un
je ne ferais pas mais il fait tous les
hypocrites
c'est pas possible parce qu'on va tous
rires non mais on sait très bien qu'il
ya des choses on va on veut mourir mais
quand ça nous visent nous avons pleuré
le but en fait toute cette histoire là
c'est un travail qu'il faut faire sur
nous mêmes faut qu'on arrête de typo
creed
enfin je sais je vous personnellement
c'est iron moi j'ai dépassé ce stade je
peux rire de moi n'y a pas de problème
si par exemple les parents meurent et
qu'on fait une blague que je la trouve
drôle je fais rire c'est être sadique
c'est peut-être complètement de foule et
moi ça me fait rire je ris ça me fait
pas rire bah je ris pas mais si je vais
pas complètement de faire une polémique
pour arrêter d'être hypocrite aux
monolines vivre et laisser vivre six
lyonnais qui veulent ouvrir et bakkies
on rit
fraises
merci beaucoup le message en fait que
j'aimerais vous faire passer c'est que
dans la crise dans cette terre à
multiples voie dans laquelle nous vivons
on est capables de se parler aussi de se
comprendre on a obtenu des résultats
certes ils valent ce qu'ils valent on
est depuis quatre ans à 1000 étudiants
formés cette année on va passer entre
800 et 1500 jeunes qui vont être
concernés par nos programmes
le conseil général de la
seine-saint-denis nous laisse désormais
travailler sur une cinquantaine de
collèges pour initier les jeunes à la
prise de parole et l'importance de la
parole citoyenne et de les impliquer
dans la vie de leur établissement
le concours et le conseil a commencé à
nanterre à grenoble à limoges mais j'ai
envie de dire on est sur quatre
universités il en existe 72
potentiellement on ne travaille avec on
a train jusqu'à 1000 jeunes jusqu ici
il en existe des millions qui seraient
prêts et qu'ils le sont parce que c'est
leur remontée de terrain gagne
génération qui est métissé qui
interconnecter les millénium qu'ils ont
ça dans leur adn
ils attendent que ça qu'on offre des
cadres éthiques st ça passe bien entendu
par les institutions l'éducation
nationale c'est se prend s'empare du
sujet sur la question de l'importance de
prise de parole mais il faut continuer
c'est d'ailleurs à mon sens l'enjeu
prioritaire de société avant même
d'essayer de nous convaincre d'être
socialiste d'être libéraux avant même
d'essayer de nous convaincre d'être de
gauche de droite avant même d'essayer de
nous convaincre qu'il faut peut-être
travailler plus ou peut-être participer
plus par l'impôt au nom d'un idéal
commun
l'enjeu au préalable c'est comment on
réapprend à communiquer dans cette terre
à multiples voix qui donne le vertige et
comment on recrée un espace et des
conditions d'un dialogue collectif qui
va permettre de co construire à nouveau
une identité citoyenne commune alors
comme le dit est dit dans le film il
faut qu'on bosse sur nous mêmes et ça
concerne toutes les personnes de la
société sans exception les riches les
pauvres les gens des banlieues les gens
de la ville les toutes les religions les
musulmans les juifs les catholiques les
boude
tout le monde est concerné c'est d'abord
pour réussir ce défi collectif de
société c'est d'abord une révolution
personnelle qu'on doit entamer sur nous
mêmes puis dans notre cercle familial
puis avec nos potes au boulot et c'est
uniquement par ce biais là et si on
prend conscience de l'urgence de cela
que on peut refaire société
collectivement et les institutions
accompagneront mais c'est d'abord une
prise de conscience qu'on doit faire
individuellement je signe chacune de mes
oeuvres par un maillon parce que
j'appartiens moi même à une chaîne nous
appartenons tous nous sommes la
génération la plus interconnecté de
l'histoire de l'humanité en vrai on est
ensemble nos vies nos destins sont liés
les uns aux autres apprenons simplement
maintenant à en parler
merci à tous
[Applaudissements]